jack straw um
yesterday must have brought back some
vivid memories of that day in 2001. what
stood out for you personally
yesterday or in 2001.
well when you think back to 2001 what
stands out i mean it was what stands out
is to simply
the way that everything changed in an
instant um
the period
really between
the collapse of the berlin wall and
after things had stabilized and
certainly
the relative stabilization in the
balkans and september the 10th 2001 had
been a pretty calm one
internationally
so nothing not a huge amount was going
on
suddenly all that changed
and
particularly for the americans because
they
had become very used over decades and
decades
to seeing their mainland territory as
completely invaluable to foreign enemies
and indeed there'd be no attack on the
us mainland since the british
navy
and marines attacked washington dc and
burnt the white house but that was in
1812 so it's really was a really deep
trauma
and that led
to
the atmosphere in which the decisions
were made not only uh in respect of
uh the invasion of afghanistan but
subsequently in respect of
iraq and
sorry
i want you to ask on that day
did you
fear
that london would also be a target
at that time
for sure yes of course
um and
uh
i don't remember but
air traffic was closed down we were
really very worried indeed because these
guys had the capability
to
hijack four
passenger planes and have trained pilots
to run into the world trade center
the pentagon and what they're hoping was
either the white house or
uh capitol hill they could easily have
done that in london for example taken
out canary wharf uh and uh the whole of
the palace of westminster house of
commons
so we were extremely worried about it
indeed
i mean
yeah
let's let's talk let's talk about what's
happened since and obviously
the most
present issue is afghanistan it's
obviously early days there but do you
believe the taliban when they say that
they're going to be different this time
well i think they'll be a bit different
because
in the last 20 years
um the majority the vast majority of
people in afghanistan particularly women
but very many men as well have learned
to enjoy
their freedoms
and
they're going to be resisting
having those taken away
also
the country is far more reliant on the
west than ever it was i mean just for
example there were actually no mobile
telephones there 20 years ago
everybody's going to become a mobile
telephone now and that requires a
reliance on overseas technical
technology
they'll also be under pressure not only
from the west but also from russia and
china although russia and china
want to
make a point against the west
they are also
petrified about islamic islamic
extremism in their own countries as well
as
in neighboring afghanistan so they will
be under greater pressure
but the question is have they feel like
changed their spots i mean my instinct
is they they haven't said they'll be
that their instinct
will be to do what they did before a key
to how they behave is the attitude of
pakistan and it's not off sufficiently
discussed this
but just bear in mind that the
intelligence inter-services intelligence
directorate of pakistan
part of their defense operation
has been
up to its neck in ventriloquising
and supporting the taliban over decades
so their attitude matters as well
what would you what would you do about
pakistan ben i mean
what how can the west use its influence
in this respect uh with difficulty but
but i mean partly listen to them and
take their advice i mean
because after
the reason they have this extremely
ambiguous relationship
with the uh taliban and with other
extremists on their north west frontier
is
is not necessarily because that the very
modern people in lahore in islamabad and
karachi
support them but they're scared of them
and it's about how you as it were
tame this tiger so listen to them i mean
one of the mistakes we did make which i
now recognize with very few of us saw at
the time
uh back in 2001 was in having no
political root out of its defeat for the
taliban
and for those forces who supported them
and coupled with that
we decided to conflate counter-terrorist
strategy which is absolutely right with
the counter-narcotic strategy which
frankly was a a bridge too far she was
taking away the livelihood
of uh people whilst you were also trying
to get them on site on counter-terrorism
um and
so we need to learn from those lessons
also be tough with them
briefly if i may um
is the biggest lesson that we should
learn from this that uh our approach to
tackling
islamist terror
has failed
and they won because we focused on the
military
when perhaps we needed to do more
to focus on what i think tony blair this
week described as the ideology winning
hearts and minds to the idea that
the west way of life democracies and so
on is better than the alternative
offered by islamists
the
i mean i don't think it's that black and
white um
in order to get
the people to listen uh and and reach
their hearts and minds in that situation
you had to at least
push the the terrorists to a draw in a
lot of parallels here in northern
ireland
um because as long as i mean these kit
they're killers uh believe aside their
ideology and as long as they think
they're winning um
they might bother to listen so but we
certainly should have done much much
more on hearts and minds